the world
singing in the car also somerset person
that always holds their note after the
song is clearly over to show off we get
it cindy you know how notes work no way
it can't be this one's just for the
commenters that said that rick might
have missed jerry being in the back seat
in a previous video dude just spotted
the glint of a gotron ferret out of the
corner of his eye from a couple hundred
thousand miles away so i think he could
clock jerry sneaking into the trash
saucer after he unlocked it chew on that
commenters look no one said i wasn't
petty it's not a gotron ferret morty
it's the blue gotron ferret so a gotron
ferret then that's how it all began to
my sister it was just another game there
will be a lot of morty and summer
narration in this episode and yes in the
end they make fun of the fact that there
was so much narration in the episode so
one might think that we would let that
go but one is naive and we'll receive 20
dings is your sentence joe thinks it's
all cute including snippets of actual
episodes in the opening credits but now
that we're here this section is
redundant and therefore wasteful and
therefore sinned mine smells skeleton
smelling your boot not only is that way
too much spaghetti and meatballs but how
exactly did they serve themselves off
that plate and leave it so undisturbed
and if they got theirs from somewhere
else why did they even make a serving
plate at all the smith family doesn't
know how to food correctly told you
let's just get gene from next door and a
homeless guy considering this episode
decides to have some actual continuity
by bringing the incest baby in space
back i'd also like to note in that exact
same episode rick runs over gene and
therefore he would not be available for
gotron activities get your asses into
some anime spacesuits and despite not
having been told where they are or given
any instructions they do rick's tube
sucks the spaghetti off but doesn't spit
any out yeah i heard it too
where are we zip-lining through
futuristic metallic tunnels too you're
going to the center of a volcano
incorrect the correct answer is you're
zip-lining to a transport chip that will
take you to the center of a volcano so
close rick so close did i just monorail
from my kitchen to hawaii just to
regroup in outer space above my kitchen
jerry and this show continue to be
excellent at tv sins i swear the show
tries to forgive its own sin so much it
might as well be well organized religion
guys we did our best they did not
i i can't believe this is working
neither can i summer and morty should
either be passed out or vomiting
profusely now after being swung around
like that not to mention they're upside
down when being fired
wow it's so ridiculous that this group
could pull all this off with no training
that i'm surprised the show hasn't sent
itself for it yet how do we just hit
buttons we're too big to fail there it
is
holy sonny d look at that purple stuff
what kind of circulatory system would be
pushing that amount of fluid through it
at that pressure even with a clean kill
i'm simply not buying this amount of kai
juice rick showing affection will never
not be weird and will always be a sin i
swear the only alien animation rule for
this show is is there somewhere you can
put a nipple or a nut sack then do it at
nip sack animation all creatures large
and small deserve vaguely sexual
external appendages having spaghetti at
a cookout hot head rick he got that name
because he was prone to dramatic
outburst explaining nicknames that needs
zero explanation oh they got him not our
problem turning a blind eye to murder go
tron montage goat montage go trash the
last time we saw morty's gotron ferret
come out of the parking garage he didn't
need to reach for a ticket he just left
furthermore why does he even need a
ticket are you saying at the end of the
adventure he comes back to the parking
garage and gets a ticket that he now
needs to leave it and those go transform
the go-go tron these transformations
make so little physical sense that it's
clear this episode attended the michael
bay school of transforming things let's
just say we're the rightful owners of
these ferrets then why were they
scattered and buried across the universe
yeah scattered and buried let's go with
that we mean in a more general cultural
sense
overly emotive anime shaming are those
boob bucks how do these three even know
he missed out on going to disneyland for
that matter how do they even know they
have the right morty morty was supposed
to be security i i stepped away all
right that's a strange way of saying you
were kidnapped dad you know that's not
what i do around here no i'm not your
dad i'm a version of him but how does he
know that's not his summer how does he
know that's the summer that is the
rick's second in command and why do all
the ricks dress differently and have
different personality traits but all the
jerry's beth mortys and summers are
virtually the same i'm not sure how this
show ever expects to be successful with
this kind of shoddy logic work i mean
look at me i'm easy to make happy which
is why nobody gives a [ __ ] i am this
statement is so depressingly true i'm
giving a sin for it which makes me happy
which means no one cares but as you guys
recall and as a lot of people keep
bringing up morty and i did accidentally
create a giant incest baby only rick and
morty could pull off a chekhov's giant
incest baby ex machina through a full
minute of exposition and still make me
consider removing sins for it instead of
adding them after further consideration
i'm adding the sins anyway because we
all have a part to play in this crazy
world and my fate was decided long ago
if this is a gotron from gotron's from
gotrons do you know how far a trip it
would be from these robotic appendages
to the head no me either but that's not
gonna keep me from sitting how
conveniently fast they got here say
hello to my little me title of my sex
tape but how did you get here where did
you find him how do you still have your
suits how did you know where rick would
be who changes the america diaper if
incest baby has to launch a missile from
his rear port man when it's time to wrap
up an episode rick and morty skips all
the interesting stuff also this is an
incest baby right do incest babies have
better capabilities to float around in
space without a suit this baby isn't a
space vehicle or the last jedi's
princess leia so what the heck is going
on here ratatouille your giant incest
space baby without explicit consent
episode does not contain a boob world
that's it
i want out of this family
since when does this house care about
alien lives we don't even watch british
television
from london
you're going to the center of a volcano
i
immediately regret this decision
[Music]
sometimes enough is enough all right
enough is enough
we're offering to help each of your
families complete their full goat
challenge in exchange for some
concession why do you have to talk to me
like that all the time right like i
gotta know something meow meow meow meow
meow meow meow
time in puerto rico when we picked up
those two uh
well i guess they were prostitutes but i
don't remember paying
oh [ __ ] you a wise man's life is based
around [ __ ] you the united states of
america is based on
[Applause]
oh that's all at once
and not
instantly to be sure